if you just become stagnant in your life
monsters will rise in your mind
if you don't act slowly they start
eating you up in so many different ways
these monsters that human beings create
in their own minds
doesn't matter in what kind of comfort
you are living in
who you are in the world
[Music]
you may be living in a palace
but monsters won't go
this is the problem with the entire
world anything that you gather can be
yours can never ever be you however
pretty your body is however sharp you
think your mind is once you're lost into
something that you are not you cannot
see life the way it is every Point
you're thinking this is it and realizing
that is not it so do you want to spend
your life like this and you sit on the
death bed and realize this is not it
that's late
that's really being late so investing
some amount of time to turn inward to
just figure what is the nature of my
life don't think this is always teaching
us something spiritual this is
fundamental
people think if they have a job if they
have a steady salary and maybe a partner
or children or home or car they think
they are having a wonderful life
but just look at their faces they are
driving their dream car
and they are stuck in the traffic are
they laughing in joy
are they extruding Bliss that in my
dream car I am sitting and the traffic
is giving me more time to sit in my
dream car they are just abusing
themselves and everybody else and the
Creator
so I am saying their idea of Wonderful
Life exists if you are enjoying things
that other people don't have I don't
call this Joy I call that sickness you
enjoy what others don't have sickness or
no
it doesn't matter who you are right now
you want to be something more there's no
question about that
if that something more happens today in
three days you will want to be something
more
you will see even if you become the
queen or king of this planet
you will look at the Moon you look at
the
planetary system you look at the
galaxies if I make you the king of one
Galaxy you will look at other galaxies
because there is something within you
which is longing to become Limitless
something within you which always wants
to expand Beyond its boundaries
things are always trying to draw
boundaries
because survival depends on boundaries
this Instinct comes to us
through our evolutionary development
we are trying to draw boundaries on one
level when we successfully draw a
boundary we feel suffocated and then we
want to expand the boundary this is the
human struggle
if we do not real realize the
possibilities if we do not realize the
many possibilities of what a human being
can be do you consider that a loss or
only if you lose something it's a loss
most people think only if I lose what I
have it's a loss
loss of possibility is the worst loss
not realizing the possibility is the
biggest loss because everything has been
lost without you knowing you lost it
human intellect is the only thing that's
destroying this world isn't it either
you destroy somebody or yourself
why is it that we don't give a sharp
knife to a child's hand not because a
knife is dangerous because the child is
unconscious and he may either harm
himself or somebody else
this is not a land of belief systems
this is a land of seekers
never ever where anybody encouraged to
believe anything
so first mistake you make is you believe
what I say I am constantly reminding you
don't believe a goddamn thing that
anybody says but don't be foolish enough
to disbelieve it either all you have to
do is experiment with it does it work or
doesn't work if it works you keep it
otherwise rubbish it what's the problem
now about somebody being hungry somebody
being homeless somebody being in a war
zones all kinds of horrible things are
happening on the planet I am not
ignorant of it I am not living in a
temple I am more of the world than you
are every day I want you to understand I
am running a volunteer organization
with over 4 000 full-time volunteers and
over 3 million part-time volunteers
doing variety of work
huge projects over a dozen businesses
and the spiritual moment okay now
I want you to understand more things are
going wrong with my life on a daily
basis than anybody's life
those who are reasonably well have never
cared to reach out and do what needs to
be done in the world in many ways
they're making sure those people don't
get it
in the year 2012 we have produced enough
food for
18.2 billion people
we had only 6.6 billion people in that
year
but still 50 of the population is
malnourished and hardly eaten anything
this is not because there is no food
because this is because you and me have
not cared so is it true nobody stabbed
you in the last 25 years yes but is it
also true you are suffering various
things of tension stress anxiety this
that is it a product of your mind or
somebody else poking you from outside
instead of seeing when there is a
problem you need empowerment not
incapacitating yourself I am talking
about empowering you so that your damn
intelligence functions for you not
against you
the moment your intelligence is working
against you no God in the universe is
going to help you and can help you if
your intelligence is turned against you
you are a finished case
so I am saying first let your
intelligence work for you if it works
for you there are many miraculous things
that you can do for all those people who
have still not eaten properly for whom
basic things have not been taken care of
that's our business because somehow
we've landed in a place where you and me
are at least eating well once we are in
such a privilege we must use our
intelligence to see what is the best
thing we can do in the world there is a
whole culture of doing something for
your satisfaction or doing something
because you want to buy a ticket to
heaven
I want people to come to a place where
you being fulfilled should happen within
you if you want to go to heaven please
leave but if you want to be a solution
there's another way to work
I fed two children and I feel very happy
so all right I appreciate that I'm glad
for those two children but this is not a
solution this is only for satisfaction
to all of you thinking oh okay some big
corporate leader I'm saying all of you
are in a certain level of capability who
should see how to bring a solution not
do something for your silly satisfaction
you can be satisfied by eating food by
simply sitting quietly by sleeping well
doing whatever
satisfaction need not come through
somebody else's suffering
somebody's suffering that is not the
basis of your suffering and if you buy a
ticket to Heaven through that suffering
I don't know heaven will turn into hell
for probably for you emotion is a very
important part of your existence because
of this silly school education that
you're getting do you think emotion is
not important but even today
most of your life is decided by the
intensity of your emotion you may think
you're very intellectual
but still your anger or your love or
your anxiety or whatever nonsensical
emotion you have is much more intense
stronger and more decisive than your
thought process for most people well
people get elected into office
because of other people's emotion so
emotion is a very juicy part of your
life and that is one thing that you can
drive up to high intensity to rev up
this body to a very high intensity takes
a lot of work
a lot of work if you want to rev up your
energies it takes a lot of work if you
want to rev up your intelligence or your
intellect to a very high intensity takes
a lot of sharpening and work but emotion
is something that most people are
capable of living it up to high pitch
only thing is they may be revving it up
in the wrong direction in an unpleasant
way their emotions are unpleasant that's
their problem
keeping your emotion Pleasant see people
who are in love people who are devotees
of something
they have the best experience of life
because their emotions are sweet
doesn't matter who's doing what
your emotions are sweet your experience
of Life is Beautiful once your life
experience is beautiful all the other
concerns are just playing so you being
in love is important
somebody is in love or not I am loving
so much are they loving me that much or
this much if you think like this you
have made your entire life transactional
in transactions you will gain ones and
lose another time endlessly trouble and
never walk in this calculation you make
your life very ugly to be with people
without any sense of what will I get you
do not know the joy of it it's
tremendously exhilarating because when
you don't care what you get
life becomes very easy and you're free